[Musica]
grazie mille buongiorno tutte un giorno
a tutti allora io partirei
come faccio spesso dalla francia perché
c'è sempre un motivo per cui il cinema è
nato in francia lo vediamo oggi
è una cosa di cui possiamo parlare dopo
c'è un signore che si chiama francois
truffaut che
tanto tempo fa disse una frase che poi
abbiamo sentito tante volte cioè che
ognuno di noi ha due professioni in
quella di la propria e quella di critico
cinematografico
vero ma oggi sappiamo che non è così
oggi tutti noi abbiamo tantissime
professioni lo vediamo sui social tutti
i giorni abbiamo la professione di
allenatore di scuola di calder di una
squadra di calcio abbiamo la professione
di virologo epidemiologo abbiamo la
professione di cuoco da seguire per
altre ricette e così via forse sempre
stato così però non lo sapevamo perché
queste cose venivano discusse magari al
bar con gli amici a pranzo pure in
stanze segrete
oggi invece abbiamo delle piattaforme
dei luoghi pubblici vasti dove poter
esibire la nostra
multiprofessionalità questo per dire che
le cose cambiano
nel 1961 un altro signore francese
jacques rivette
scrive sul numero 120 dei cahier du
cinéma di vista senza la quale non
saremmo nemmeno più a parlare di critica
oggi è senza la quale ovviamente non ci
sarebbe nemmeno il cinema moderno come
interpretiamo scrive un articolo che si
chiama dell'abiezione
sull'obiezione
e jacques rivette
che non era affatto uno stupido anzi era
21 dei più grandi che gi situazione del
cinema è un grandissimo critico se la
prende con un film un film che si
intitola capo di gillo pontecorvo
rivette dice che
c'è una scelta di pontecorvo che ha
profondamente immorale
nel momento in cui il personaggio
interpretato da emanuele riva nel film
decide di suicidarsi in un campo di
concentramento
gettandosi contro una rete elettrificata
rivet si ricorda che c'è un carrello in
avanti che se fa spettacolo che crea un
pathos posticcio la macchina si muove in
fatica quella morte in realtà ripeto non
si ricordava benissimo perché a rivedere
il film movimento è veramente
impercettibile
cosa ci dice anche tante cose delle cose
che cambiano oggi figli possiamo
rivedere studiare un po meglio il punto
però è che in quel momento un critico
cinematografico
dice sua lettori in cosa è giusto e cosa
non è giusto fare cosa è lecito e cosa
non è lecito quello che è morale
al tempo però siamo nel 1961 il cinema è
ancora luogo di elaborazione
dell'immaginario principale la
televisione c'è da pochi anni non è che
anche diffusa o comunque ci sono pochi
canali
i programmi sono limitati eccetera
eccetera oggi
usare quell'insegnamento di jacques
rivette è semplicemente stupito
e importante che ci sia stato perché
senza quell insegnamento non avremmo
potuto pensare il cinema un certo modo è
un insegnamento che ha portato tanti
film
il cahier du cinéma sapete hanno dato
vita a una classe di
registi che hanno cambiato la storia del
cinema e devono tutti i registi critici
che se la prendevano ad esempio con i
padri che volevano discostarsi da quello
che era il cinema dei padri oggi quando
rivediamo i film dei padri che loro
hanno ucciso scopriamo che erano di film
bellissimo
questo però non è tanto un problema il
problema è che per esempio se ne usiamo
degli strumenti del 1961 per raccontare
le immagini di oggi per analizzarle
stiamo facendo un grosso
per esempio l'ultima volta che ho
sentito cose ho sentito usare
il piccolo dell'abiezione sul carrello
di capo
è per un film di gianfranco rosi
notturno gianfranco rosi fa un film
molto particolare
decide di andare in medio oriente iren
diversi luoghi gira i luoghi dove c'è o
c'è stata la guerra ma non racconta mai
la guerra ci fa vedere sempre le cose
dopo
il soprattutto fa una cosa particolare
ci fate vedere delle immagini belle e
devono creare del piacere nello
spettatore ora se ne usiamo
l'insegnamento di rivetta per guardare
le immagini di rosi indiremo quelle
immagini sono immorali
quelle immagini non sono giuste non sono
lecite fanno spettacolo laddove lo
spettacolo non ci deve essere ma le cose
cambiano
oggi noi lo dicevamo prima vediamo
tantissime immagini al tempo no al tempo
potevano esserci delle regole oggi non
ci sono oggi se noi guardiamo il
classico colonnino a destra del
i quotidiani nazionali sui siti vediamo
magari sceglie di incidente testo e
tagliati dai terroristi e sotto magari
un simpatico coniglietto puccioso
immediatamente dopo
oggi le immagini sono delle immagini in
qualche modo
indifferenti né vediamo troppo
le cose cambiano anche la moralità
cambia
un'immagine per essere un morale può
fare anche altro per esempio c'è un
regista che si chiama gasparino è che
nel 2003 gira un film che si chiama il
riverside in questo film c'è una scena
di stupro di 9 minuti
violentissima il fatto è che gasparino
egira questo film
lavorando sulle frequenze sonore con cui
la polizia debella le folle che ha dei
fastidio allora ci fa vedere una cosa ma
nel frattempo lavora sul nostro corpo
per far sì che quella cosa sia
disgustosa
al nostro fisico cioè crea un'immagine
scioccante e ci punge di più
rivetta avrebbe detto che quella cosa
immorale ma oggi gaspar noè decide che
per raccontare quella cosa deve togliere
un'immagine disturbo dall indifferenza
delle immagini e quindi ce la fa subire
in maniera insistente ce la fa subire
contro il nostro fisico e quindi fa
qualcosa che
ci fa ridiscutere mette il nostro corpo
e la nostra esperienza di fronte alle
immagini in una mania che non è più
indifferente
gianfranco rosi quando va in medio
oriente e fa notturno fa un film dove
l'immagine è bella in qualche modo cerca
di redimere la bruttezza della guerra
tramite le immagini sono immagini
estetizza te sì ma bisogna essere
consapevoli quando si fa critica oggi
che oggi i reportage di guerra non si
stampano più sulle riviste vanno nelle
gallerie d'arte
c'è un'idea anche di economia
dell'immagine un'immagine bella può
essere un'immagine che ci tocca e ci
punge che si toglie dall indifferenza
delle immagini noi siamo abituati spesso
è un'immagine del dolore deve essere
un'immagine che usa una retorica come
dire
sgranata brutta che non si compiace di
quello che ci mostra invece può anche
essere il contrario può essere che un
immagine per farsi sentire per pungerci
per dirci qualcosa per farci ridiscutere
il nostro rapporto con le immagini può
essere qualcosa che 60 anni fa veniva
considerata immorale
le cose cambiano la critica oggi è
ovunque dicevamo prima tutti i panifici
cinematografici tutti hanno una platea
per fare i critici cinematografici
mi fa un po ridere
il
l'idea che per parlare di cinema ci
debba essere un patentino però anche una
cosa un po fascista perché tutti non
possono parlare di cinema ben venga che
tutti parlano di cin parlino di cinema
ma un critico deve sapersi distinguere
deve
lavorare sulla propria autorevolezza e
come si fa forse oggi
proprio perché le cose cambiano proprio
perché non bisogna dare le risposte e
non bisogna dire questo giusto questo
sbagliato come facevano i critici negli
anni 60 oggi forse un buon critico e un
critico che non è ottuso e non si
schiera che non
sceglie la propria posizione ma anzi si
pone delle domande continua a porsi
delle domande
non partecipa alla polarizzazione del
dibattito che sta intorno questo
permessi questo per me non ho un buon
critico oggi si pone continuamente in
discussione
quando una cosa non ti piace
ti chiede chi perché non ti piace che
cosa sta facendo
questo film su di te se una cosa ti dà
fastidio perché ti dà fastidio di
richiede i peccati sta dando fastidio
quando arrivi a un punto fermo di
mettere una virgola
perché a quel punto fermo può essere una
su una prima impressione può essere
qualcosa che
da cui puoi andare più in fondo io credo
che oggi
un buon critico se un critico che si
mette da parte
fa un passo indietro
si fa riempire dalle immagini da agio a
quello che si sta guardando
a questo punto di solito i miei studenti
ho i miei collaboratori dicono pessima
se mi metto se io non mi sono mi fermo
mai se mi metto continuamente in
dialettica se ogni volta che arriva un
punto devo mettere una virgola ok ma
quand'è che do un giudizio
quand'è che posso dire se una cosa vale
o non vale
allora io penso che per essere un buon
critico oggi
bisogna avere due movimenti 1 un
movimento di umiltà di mettere
continuamente in discussione proprio
gusto li mette in continuamente in
discussione quello che si pensa ma
dall'alto bisogna avere un movimento di
ambizione di grandezza cioè di pensare
che non è tanto il tuo punto di vista
che conta non è tanto il tuo gusto che
conta ma devi avere la responsabilità di
prendere le parti della storia del
cinema della sua progressione
dell'economia dell'immaginario
contemporaneo
dell'economia delle immagini passate
presenti e ipotizzare delle immagini
future
questo significa che quando si vede un
film dopo che ci si è messi in
discussione bisogna pensare a come
questo film dialoga con le immagini che
stanno intorno che possono essere le
immagini dei reportage fotografici belli
nelle gallerie bisogna pensare al fatto
che l'arte contemporanea perlopiù lavora
sulla esperienza estetica in un solo
oggetto e quindi sono importanti le
reazioni in dello pubblico e non tanto
quello che c'è sullo schermo bisogna
allenarsi a guardare le cose sotto un
altro punto di vista e
pensare se un film
sposta qualcosa nella storia del cinema
sposta qualcosa nell'economia delle
immagini di oggi e per ritornare a
quello che diceva truffaut tuffo dice un
film deve avere una visione di cinema
una visione di mondo
secondo me oggi
in un momento in cui il cinema non è più
l'occhio del novecento non è più l'arte
primaria luogo di elaborazione
dell'immaginario bisogna anche pensare
che il cinema è anche un luogo che
ripensa le immagini che ci fa pensare al
nostro rapporto con le immagini
e quindi un buon film è un buon politico
sono colore sono coloro che mettono in
dischi mettono in discussione ma al
contempo
pensano a
rapporto tra quello che noi vediamo e le
immagini che ci stanno intorno lo
mettono in crisi lo mettono in forse io
penso che oggi
siano questi due i movimenti uno è
quello di essere umili di mettersi da
parte di farsi parlare soprattutto
perché bisogna porsi delle domande là
dove tutti hanno delle risposte
ma l'altra quello di conoscere conoscere
la storia del cinema andare alle mostre
leggere libri perché solo così si può
avere la responsabilità di prendere le
parti della storia del cinema e
dell'economia dell'immaginario grazie
[Applauso]